si los civiles siguen siendo blancos de
ataques en la guerra de ucrania esta
mañana un misil una parte de un misil a
caído sobre un edificio ubicado en un
barrio residencial de la capital de
ucrania kiev causando la muerte de al
menos una persona y también tenemos
informaciones de que en hardcore las
autoridades ucranianas han denunciado un
bombardeo contra un edificio que alberga
un centro educativo una noticia que
coincide también con la preocupación que
hay por el teatro de mariupol
bombardeado hacer y en el que se
albergaban a decenas de civiles civiles
que incluso habían escrito la palabra
niño en el intento de evitar este ataque
algo que no pudo hacer por su parte el
ministro de interior de ucrania ha dicho
que ya en todo el país hay infiltrados
rusos con lo cual a esto incluso también
el oeste de ucrania donde nos
encontramos en este momento